on se dit pas que c'est sorti de tout là
quand même regarde mais sors de l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au Brésil pour s'offrir un voyage pour
se retrouver et comme la Mina Bila dans
sa story Instagram ce voyage serait une
détox du couple pour eux c'est ce dont
on avait besoin
#etox et récemment donc par on a 2e
garçon ça en sait le couple traversait
une période compliquée bah c'est vrai
qu'elle a eu deux enfants très
rapprochés qu'elle a eu ces deux
grossesses et puis qu'après ben
forcément quand on dit de grossesse
comme ça on a besoin de se retrouver un
peu avec son mari j'ai trouvé femme se
retrouver homme
ils avaient besoin de se retrouver de se
retrouver amoureux et c'est bien je
trouve parce que il préserve leur couple
si tu viens pour nous sortir des trucs
de presse dit la vérité la vérité va
être là
j'ai passé deux trois coups de fil et ce
qu'on m'a dit ils sont tout va très bien
il y a aucun problème simplement c'est
vrai qu'il travaille ensemble ils ont eu
un deuxième enfant cette année donc
forcément c'est juste le genre de rumeur
qui entoure leur coupe depuis des années
ça va super beau
tu as annoncé il y a pas longtemps c'est
vrai qu'en revanche financièrement c'est
plus compliqué tu vis du RSA c'est vrai
ça c'est quoi le reste ça c'est 400
euros par mois
530 euros par mois ou tu vis en fait tu
partages un peu ta ta maison entre entre
ta maman et
Eric prayer ton meilleur ami dans le sud
de la France c'est ça beaucoup chez ma
maman oui donc tu es un peu itinéraire
personne ne me croit même ma famille mes
amis ne m'ont pas cru ma maman comme on
vit beaucoup ensemble et qu'on est
beaucoup plus proche le remarque
maintenant il est vrai que dès qu'il y a
des souple licencieux mon compte ils
sont souvent en soufflés dans
l'appartement de Lyon
plus pour faire bannir non j'aime pas
parler d'argent parce que
il est où cet argent justement
j'ai pas d'appart j'ai pas de c'est
bizarre quand même avec tout cet argent
tout est parti tout est parti et ben de
la banque donc déjà on fait du bien
ou ta maman je veux pas dire j'accuse
personne
je suis je suis justement donc j'ai pas
utilisé mon agent ci bien sûr parce que
ça fait quand même assez longtemps que
je les vends je sais que vous êtes
réconcés avec ta maman mais si par
hasard
tu découvrais que cette enquête que
l'argent qui a été tiré c'était souvent
ta maman tu lui en voudrais beaucoup
mais comment tu pourrais
quand dire
par mais c'est qui
des pâtes donc franchement elle me
révolé cet argent
même pas il y a des malfrats où j'en
sais rien ma mère l'a vu une fois j'ai
travaillé j'ai mis le rose sur mon
compte cinq jours plus tard il reste 70
on a parlé c'était tenté de suicide dieu
merci et non pas été réussi
ce genre de choses là ou pas rien on
peut te dire voilà ça fait 10 ans j'ai
arrêté la drogue l'alcool
que j'entends ce soir
ou comme ça on dit elle est défoncer je
vais te dire pourquoi
parce que regarde quand on regarde ton
Instagram on a vu un pas longtemps on se
dit il y a est-ce qu'on peut en voir un
Instagram ou tu annonçais que tu pouvais
faire des vidéos et tout ça si on peut
le voir s'il vous plaît voilà Lolo on se
dit pas que c'est une fille qui est
sorti de tout là quand même regarde mais
sors de l'eau Lolo s'il te plaît pas à
moi je suis pas des conneries écoute
genre allez comme ça elle est comme ça
ben voilà me dis pas que tu es dans un
état là tu es pas nickel c'est le
discours il est 9h du matin mais c'est
pas le problème
[Rires]
de love story ils sont assez désagréable
quand il parle de vous il vous il vous
dénigre pas mal je trouve et voilà ils
vous ont lâché totalement et ils disent
limite pour certains non mais nous on
veut pas ça y est on a tout enfin limite
c'est honteux pour eux enfin moi je le
ressens comme ça ça vous fait quoi de
voir ce cet humiliant quand même vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
me fait mal au cœur humiliant non j'en
ai rien à faire ça me touche à
l'intérieur
j'aimerais qu'on te montre une photo
quand tu revois cette photo là qu'est-ce
que tu as envie de dire à cette jeune
fille dit à 20 ans à peu près Loana
aujourd'hui et plus attention et ben
c'est ce que je te dis aussi aujourd'hui
et elle a été photographiée dans les
rues de Londres arborant une robe où
elle est pratiquement nue à deux minutes
laissant apparaître pratiquement
l'intégralité de sa poitrine et donc ses
fans comme c'est comme ceux qu'il a
critique depuis longtemps c'est des
tracteurs se demandent si elle n'a pas
replongé totalement excusez-moi
une Europe décolleté on voit un joli
sein sur un mannequin ça en fait droguer
on appelle ça un décolleté toi ça c'est
un décolleté jusqu'au nombril ce n'est
pas un décolleté Mathieu c'est une
soirée avec elle il y a une monnaie
[Applaudissements]
et donc elle était là entourée de garde
du corps elle était déjà à moitié à poil
comme ça très joli il y a quelques
semaines entouré de garde du corps elle
avait un charisme fou quand le passé les
gens s'écartaient de même pas besoin du
corps les gens s'écartaient devant elle
et cetera elle est fantastique pour moi
c'est une Brico
et on rappelle quand même que ça
rapportait je crois après 2 millions
d'euros pour pour l'association donc ça
c'est très très important et on sera
toujours derrière en revanche
effectivement oui il y a pas aussi la
chanson italienne en détresse peut-être
que personne pouvait la chanter pour moi
c'était son hit c'est bizarre qu'il
n'est pas mis mais toi effectivement
Francesca et je sais que tu as été peiné
vraiment pas parce que tu as pas été à
l'antenne ben parce qu'à la base je
crois que vous étiez tous prévu c'est ça
les anciens plus ou moins que ça allait
être le cas moi je voilà je vais être
raisonnée de vous me connaissez ici moi
je dis les choses telles que je les
pense j'adore la star acade je la suis
je prie tout le temps dessus donc voilà
sur le moment ça m'a un petit peu touché
on a vu des images des photos de nous en
plus des idées derrière on les a vu tous
chanter ça fait partie de notre histoire
bon voilà je trouvais juste ça dommage
qu'on soit pas là qu'on soit pas aussi
là pour rendre hommage parce que pour
moi Zazie elle a pas plus de légitimité
que nous à rendre hommage à Grégory
Lemarchal et encore moins de feu de
chatterton que dont j'avais jamais
entendu parler avant donc c'était les
chanteurs voilà moi je pense qu'on avait
notre place parce qu'on avait envie de
lui rendre hommage et que voilà ça on
avait tous un pinceau au cœur après
passer ça l'important évidemment c'est
d'avoir récolté des don on continue à
envoyer grève au 92,77 et c'est le plus
important il y a pas de débat mais sur
le moment
on l'ignorait totalement quand on
regarde la télévision est-ce que c'est
vrai que par exemple avoir un prime il
avait par exemple des kinés et que
c'était à pleurer qui faisait cracher il
y a pas d'autres mots ce qu'il avait
dans les poumons cracher craché pour
pouvoir chanter derrière dans des
douleurs affreux tout ça c'était vrai ce
que je peux dire c'est que Greg
souffrait évidemment énormément de sa
maladie et que le seul moment où on
voyait pas sa maladie c'est le moment il
chantait